[Musique]
nathalie wolf bonjour bonjour alors on
est avec hervé hamon on va on va voyager
on va peut-être rêver mais pas seulement
pour le dictionnaire amoureux des îles
bonjour hervé rebonds bonjour alors je
présente rapidement vous êtes philosophe
de formation vous êtes écrivain à la
fois romancier essayiste évidemment tout
le monde se souvient des des grands best
seller écrit avec patrick rotman le
grand livre de 68 les intellocrates la
bio dividende
le grand lac de 77 génération pardon
hein et puis vous avez publié seul titre
personnel si je peux dire beaucoup de
lit beaucoup drôle de livre des essais
des romans notamment autour de la mer il
ya la baillie d'ouessant il ya besoin de
mer paquebot et vous publié aux éditions
plon donc après le dictionnaire amoureux
de la mer de yann queffélec un
dictionnaire amoureux des îles merci
donc d'être avec nous nathalie je vois
là se prendre le large
oui allait prendre le large bonjour
avoue hervé hamon merci de votre
présence
alors il y à autant de manières d'écrire
des dictionnaires amoureux qui lie à
d'auteur de ses dictionnaires mais
généralement mais généralement des
introductions sont courtes et on la
vôtre qui s'intitule observations
préalables
elle est relativement longue d'une
vingtaine de pages ça s'explique pour
deux raisons la première on va y revenir
parce qu'il faut bien déterminer ce
qu'est une île et la deuxième et on va
commencer par là c'est que l'on perçoit
que après que vous ayez accepté d'écrire
ce dictionnaire vous ai dit au fond la
tâche
elle est immense peut-être inhumaine
alors vous vous l'écrivez un d'ailleurs
je sais une chose c'est que nul n'a
jamais fait le tour du monde
donc hervé hamon comment est ce que vous
avez résolu
problème qui consistait à faire face à
cette immensité se vivre vient de 35 ans
de navigation et puis trois ans et demi
de travail et devant l'immensité
effectivement sujet puisque le sujet
c'est le monde donc il faut bien faire
des choix
je me suis dit que j'allais d'abord
faire les miches au coeur c'est derrière
les endroits que je connaissais les i je
suis allée de par le monde
oui aussi près de chez vous rabhi sujet
j'ai eu la chance de mettre devant la
mer et la une des premières choses que
j'ai vue dans ma vie ce sont les huiles
et puis c'est aussi les choses fortes
qui vont marquer dans l'histoire parce
que je suis aussi un historien suffi aux
offres multi os historien de formation
j'ai travaillé de ce côté là et j'ai
renoncé complètement à faire un palmarès
des îles 0 l'idée que celle ci est plus
belle que ces lettres toutes les 800
sont intéressantes sont mal mais il y en
a qui ont des histoires plus fortes qui
sont plus grandes que les autres et
c'est celle là que j'ai retenu témoigner
puisque là le principe de cette
collection est que l'auteur a su sa
totale subjectivité et quand je vais
vous avez raison de relever le fait que
je dis que personne je me souviens de 10
points foughali yater quand il avait
remporté le vendée globe et il me disait
trop tôt le disait tu sais tu fais le
tour du monde et j'ai vu trois femmes et
je pense que personne n'a et puis j'ai à
épuiser le monde et ses nerfs quelque
chose qui me réjouit c'est à dire que je
parle de beaucoup d'îles et il nous
reste encore beaucoup d'autres préfèrent
on préfère 15 ans tient ce moment
d'ailleurs vous le rappeler alors
nathalie disais ouais il faut bien
définir ce que c'est une île vous dit de
vous dit bah oui c'est pas un bateau
immobile une île c'était ville c'est une
montagne vous rappeler que à l'origine
de tout d'ailleurs c'est la mer il ya la
mère papa la terre exactement
et pour faire ce livre j'ai pris le
point de vue de bleus même si j'ai pensé
que 80% de ceux qui recourent ou à la
planète chelloa et que les îles sont des
montagnes ce ne sont pas des navires
allant kraft ce sont des montagnes même
même les i une folie lille 2 à 4
centimètres au dessus des eaux
c'est une mentalité ça vient du fond ça
vient du fond de la mer et au fond tous
les continents sont désignés simplement
les géographes décide de passer il
[Musique]
ce qui ce qui n'est pas trop grand et
c'est par exemple le groenland est
classée comme une île alors qu' on ne le
dira pas de la sibérie mais cette idée
du point de vue de la mer vous fait
percevoir les choses très différemment
de façon plus originale parce que les
îles c'est finalement là la plaque
sensible
la pointe avancée de de notre vie
terrestre
l'ajustement est alors de ce
dictionnaire aux médias parce qu'il
regorge d'histoires héros d'hier il ya
presque des romans à sa queue à sa
contrée d'aidé destinée à examiner une
chose qu'on dont on s'aperçoit quand on
lit ce livre et vous ne savez peut-être
pas vos c'est qu'au fond l'histoire des
îles elle est relativement trazic
souvent et est alors comment on explique
que lille provoque encore dans le coeur
de chacun va leur rêve
le pli des du paradis et pas seulement
d'ailleurs de paradis fiscaux j'ai
tranché cda pour ça c'est un magnifique
sujet vivent c'est lille sa porte
non seulement un imaginaire mais tous
les imaginaires bottines lille ça
commence avant lille
commence dans le voyage vers l'île et
ont voyagé vers les in toutes sortes de
gens ont voyagé vers les îles des gens
qui étaient des déportés des réfugiés
ont voyagé vers les in les gens qui
rêvait ni de merveilleuses dans un
domaine pur vous allez pouvoir être en
en sérénité avec la mer ont voyagé vers
les îles des migrants ont voyagé vers
les îles des commerçants ont voyagé vers
les îles des militaires des conquérants
de tout cela de tout cela ça raconte
l'histoire des îles et les ils ne sont
jamais sein des revenus même même luc
ranque est la plus jolie des îles
j'ai pas le direct chose est par exemple
je m'occupe chose est elle a une cote
oran m côte-sous-le-vent la côte au vent
c'est une côte qui est agressé papale
paraissait en parle c'est une cause qui
est défendue par la roche
et puis la côte sous le vent c'est le
côté bahamas de l'est et c'est pourquoi
les ide sont comporte toujours ce
paradoxe cette contradiction est et
entre les îliens même et elle ils sont
toujours différencié
mais les yvelines sont à la fois
totalement uni vers ils font grand
continentaux mais en même temps il
souffre aussi dix ans aussi facilement
beaucoup de nuances de paradoxes et vous
expliquer d'ailleurs d'en parler
s'agissant de belle île ou de l'île de
ré que cet endroit soit soient devenus
des lieux où il faut aller où il faut
être vu quand on est artiste quand un
homme politique quand on est
personnalité oui je sais pas mon côté le
plus
le côté de mon côté de plus aimable sa
préférée l'île de ré les plus iniques
pour moi c'est clair parce qu'ils ont
construit un pont partir du moment où il
se relie par rapport au continent savais
plus ce que membre à la définition
géographique et belle-ile oui c'est le
plat history un peu comme les images et
c'est intéressant mais moi les îles qui
passionne le plus c'est quand même ses
désirs qui ne sont pas touchées par le
tourisme de masse
je pense que c'est un phénomène très
récent
le le côté celle fix you laissez moi
elle mont saint michel est comme ça ça
ça me ça me débecte de beaucoup je pense
que est d'ailleurs beaucoup divier
réfléchissent et sont en train de se
prémunir en poste à parce que ça n'ait
pu lille quand on regarde ces on se
regarde soit devant lille il n'est plus
qu'un décor et je pense que là qu'on
perd beaucoup vous dit d'ailleurs qu'il
ya des paysages vers l'est du golfe de
morbihan de cette petite île de berder
vous aviez quand vous étiez enfant on
vous dit maintenant il ya manier même
presque plus de paysages maritimes en
phase avec cette triste quoi c'est
devenir un lot de résidences secondaires
nathalie justement dans ces îles
lointaines est-ce qu'il y en a une qui
vous fascine en particulier nous envoler
j'ai ouvert un paradis des risques par
exemple sur les îles palaos en
micronésie
elle s'est d'ailleurs pas des îles c'est
un archipel qui est répandu sur 1 sur 1
qu'il d'immenses distance et les
panneaux c'est un des plus beaux récif
corallien du monde et ils ont la sagesse
de gérer bien leur tourisme et même de
l'europe de demander aux touristes de ne
pas s' enfuir d'huile pour bronzer ou
pour se protéger du soleil
certains crient et dansent et il aura un
sens très fort de l'écologie des risques
climatiques en parle et qui atteignent
les gilles directement et bien c'est
très soigneusement gérer je passerais
bien une petite quinzaine aux palaos oui
je vous la recommande mêlée laso il que
j'admire beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup et sens chez moi bien
sûr mais j'aime beaucoup
une île de ta par exemple en polynésie à
côté de la terre croisé en bateau et sur
les lagons de villota au moment du
cocher ou g10 analyse c'est en effet les
grand plaisir des yeux et l'âme l'egypte
est tout d'abord quand même parce que
beaucoup d'entre elles sont très très
belle très très belle et puis vous
prêtez vous il ya votre côté à peu 68
heures quand même vous parlait il ya
dans les îles seguin quand même bon avec
avec renault etc
non on n'a plus trop le temps de parler
c'est vrai que vous parler d'écologie
est très important la situation d une
part élevée par rapport à
l'environnement mais je crois que
nathalie vous lui posez une question sur
une île qui vous est cher oui qu'est
rapport avec la littérature évidemment
oui parce que vous parlez aussi des îles
qui sont celles des écrivains et on peut
pas ne pas évoquer victor hugo et
guernesey
je crois que c'est nul que vous adorez
c'est ce qu'on lit en tout cas dans
votre livre où se trouve votre ville
raus cette étrange maison et vous vous
dites quelle étrange et pourquoi est ce
qu'elle est cette maison où fait peur
alors à ce que sais je
si vous avez visité la maison la maison
de victor hugo
c'est une raison qui va dit chambre vers
la lumière
au fur et à mesure qu'on monte des
étages alors la pièce de cristal là où
il écrivait sur le paf l'en face à face
à la mer passe à les fermer le sarc
ça c'est une pièce qui me va très bien
mais le reste est terrible parce que
c'est extraordinairement encombré il
n'ya pas y'a pas un centimètre carré de
mu qui soient couverts qui nous ce qui
déçoit son petit show 6,6 et de victor
hugo
c'est bien il ya un côté il ya un an
toutes les chaises sont marqués dh bhv à
je vous dis on étouffe l'attend on
étouffe là dedans on se dit que c'est
peut-être le fruit d'un 2,2 selon selon
l'exil il a passé 15 ans à écrire ce
grand livre et donc elle est passionnant
d'avoir des moines
oui obtient peu des jeux je
m'installerai pas pour vivre dans ce
réseau là évidemment pour rester des
heures avec vous parce qu'on s'évade on
voyage mais voilà malheureusement le
temps qui nous est imparti comme on dit
est dépassé alors on va renvoyer à ce
dictionnaire amoureux des îles
voilà vous allez voyager c'est vous
mêmes même si on se dit qu'on finit un
peu dans quelques temps ben c'est un
formidable voyage avec avec quand même
cette idée qu'il dit c'est pas forcément
toujours le le phare niet le soleil
c'est autre chose de sa vie c'est la vie
merci infiniment hervé hamon merci
pourquoi
[Musique]